I think you're going to like this next story.
Devin Nunez is a Republican Congressman.
He's filthy.
Okay.
He's been wrapped up with the white house
and with the sketchiness of trying to have
foreign powers smear Joe Biden way back when,
before the 2018 midterms when the house Intel
committee, uh, was working, uh, was investigating
Trump Nunez was on the committee and he was
going to the white house to tell Trump what
they were doing.
Uh, he has been traveling around the world
for meetings that he shouldn't be having.
And he was one of the people asking questions
during the house intelligence committees,
uh, impeachment hearings just a couple of
months ago when in reality he should have
been a witness, right?
He should have been on the receipt.
He should have been answering questions not
asking them because of his involvement.
So one of the things that was alleged a couple
months ago was that Devin Nunez had been in
touch directly with Rudy Giuliani's henchman
Lev Parness by phone.
Let me remind you the connection.
Donald Trump has a personal lawyer, Rudy Giuliani,
Rudy Giuliani is peddling influence and getting
smear campaigns going, uh, to help Donald
Trump.
Rudy has two henchmen working for him or used
to until they were indicted.
Lev Parness and Igor Fruman, they go all over
the world.
They do dirty work.
They're doing surveillance on people.
They're making deals influencing people doing
Trump's V bidding through Rudy Giuliani when
it was previously alleged thanks to leaked
phone records that Devin Nunez had direct
phone calls with left Parness.
He couldn't remember it.
He denied it.
It didn't trigger anything in his memory.
Now we knew he was lying.
It was suggested.
Maybe someone took Devon's phone and called
loved Parness.
If you can believe that, check this out from
December.
Well, you know what w what did you discuss
with love?
Parness
well, I don't even know because I don't, I've
never met Parnas and like I filed in federal
court and so you know, it's a great question
because many people want to know, including
myself.
So
yeah, you never had any phone conversation
with him?
We, we have not been able to confirm that
yet.
You, I mean you don't, you don't think you
would remember if you had a [inaudible]
you have to, you have to remember.
You have to remember we are the house intelligence
committee oversight committee.
Okay.
So we get calls from people every day, all,
all walks of life.
I get them from all over the world
now.
At the time, if you could read between the
lines, you could tell that he was lying.
I have never met Lev Parness while we're talking
about phone calls, did you talk on the phone?
We've not been able to confirm that.
I talked on the phone with him.
I get many calls from different people, very
transparently lying, but cut to last night
or the night the night before.
Actually, Rachel Maddow on MSNBC interviews,
Rudy Giuliani's henchmen, Lev Parness.
And what a coincidence.
Right after Lev Parness tells Rachel Maddow,
everybody was involved.
Trump all the way down.
Devin Nunez suddenly remembers the phone call.
Check this out.
Devin Nunez back on Fox news two nights ago
talking about it.
Some things seems to have jogged his memory
and yeah, you have to remember this is someone,
a matter of fact, I think I came on your show,
Martha, this person accused me of being in
Vienna.
Him and his lawyers accused me of being in
Vienna, meeting with Ukrainians in 2018 with
him.
I mean, this is someone who doesn't tell the
truth.
That's something that didn't happen.
So this person has a real problem with the
truth.
Not to mention he's been indicted.
Very, very strange.
Yeah.
And we also talked back then about the fact
that your phone number showed up with calls
to him to live Parness, um, in, in a like
list of data numbers.
And you said that you didn't recall, uh, speaking
with him, um, or whether it was on your cell
phone or your office phone.
Have you, have you figured out the answer
to any of those questions?
If
you, if you recall that was brand new and
that had come out when I came on your show
because just didn't, I just didn't know the
name.
This name.
Parnas so, you know what I always like to
remind people is, you know, we are dealing
with people every day.
We're an oversight committee.
So we have incoming calls that come to my
office, to my cell phone, et cetera, et cetera.
And then, you know, you know, now that, uh,
he had called my cell phone, uh, and I didn't
know his name, I didn't remember the name,
but I did remember going back looking at where
I was at the time.
Cause you know, you can do that now.
You actually know where you physically are.
Checked it with my records.
Right.
And it was very clear.
I remember, I remember that call, uh, which
was very odd, random talking about random
things and I said, great, you know, just talk
to my staff and boom, boom, boom.
And that's, which is
about the Ukrainian ambassador.
There was no, was there any discussion about
the Ukrainian ambassador and the fact that
she should be removed in that call?
Well, the first time I remember the name Evanovich
the ambassador was not until this impeachment
sham started
total liar.
Can't be trusted.
Oh, I denied the phone calls, but I did talk
to him.
But he's the guy that you can't trust.
Great.
He remembers the call and he remembers talking
about random things.
Does anybody believe that left Parness had
a random call with Devin Nunez who Nunez didn't
know but still pass to staff for followup.
So of course the goalposts are being moved
first.
There was no recollection of the call left.
Parness doesn't ring a bell.
What are people talking about now?
It's, you know, I did get a call from him.
I remember that it was just a random call,
but I did pass it to my staff for followup.
We'll follow up about what if it was a random
call about nothing.
None of it is believable, and also does anyone
believe that Devin Nunez was in touch with
Trump?
Parness and Giuliani all along and never heard
the name Maria Bonovitch uttered until the
impeachment hearing started.
He's coming up with more lies, unforced lies,
unless maybe they are forced because we don't
understand how deepen it he is and he is one
of the most dishonest players in this entire
thing.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at D Pacman.
I do want to hear from you